hello and welcome back to las vegas now
it's time to get
cooking nanny bubbe is joining us live
via skype to share a delicious
sheet pan recipe hello
hello lindsay i'm so happy to be back
with you i'm so happy you're back from
maternity leave and i
i want to take 20 seconds out of my own
segment to tell you and everyone out
there in tv land
to tune in to your instagram page
because it is the cutest thing i've ever
seen it's fun it's
beautiful and above all else it's funny
you're adorable so
thank you you're so sweet we're gonna
get back to cooking now yes
we're making a sheet man sheet pan
chicken fried dinner
with miso and ginger so the first thing
i want to remind you
is never cook on top of aluminum sheet
pans are
all aluminum i lined mine first with the
silicone
silicone wire and then i put parchment
right over the top of that
to separate it and you ask why lindsay
why
why why why yes thank you because
aluminum is toxic and you want to not
put toxicity into any of your foods
so let's start now with the bok choy so
we're going to put in
quartered bok choy right on top of the
sheet pan there we go maybe i cut a
little bit
too many but that's okay we're going to
do carrots and
all the vitamins and carrots are in the
skin so i don't peel these
i just wash them really well as you
learned with the food grade hydrogen
peroxide
right sprinkle in because that adds
color
and then we're going to add fennel okay
so here is a fennel bulb
just in case you don't remember what
fennel looks like and
right onto the pan now we're going to
spray this
reaching over spray it with olive oil to
toss
a little bit of salt and pepper there we
go
a little pepper a little salt
we're going to toss it okay there we go
all tossed in so now we're going to make
a fabulous
paste for on top of the chicken thighs
so can you see these chicken thighs here
yes i've blotted them with a paper towel
i'm also going to spray them with a
little olive oil
and then that way the paste we're going
to make is going to stick
really well so if you're ready we are
going to start with six
tablespoons of olive oil okay everybody
loves olive oil right
there we go that's about six tablespoons
two tablespoons of the mustard
there we go just regular mustard or
no thank you for asking that and you
always catch these things and i'm so
appreciative
it's the stone ground mustard okay and
or dijon mustard that you want to put in
we're going to put in a heaping
tablespoon of miso
so you know i made this for my husband
and he explained with joy oh my god
marla this is delicious
and i think it's because i used
ingredients that i don't normally use in
my cooking like miso
and like three tablespoons of ginger and
you want to grate the ginger
that just fell all over the floor
two table thank you two tablespoons of
orange zest
three tablespoons of garlic oh my god
right
and i want to just remind you if you're
going to zest the skin of an orange make
sure that you cool it
there we go and then we're going to put
in
the scallions so some scallions right
there right
and also we need i do need a knife
which i missed but i don't have a knife
and i oh right here
i need two tablespoons sixty right i
need two tablespoons of orange juice i
could tell that it was not quite liquidy
enough
so there we go and we're going to take
this mix it around
all going like this i think i need a
little more olive oil
and we are going to paste this right
onto
the chicken skins okay
all right how are we doing on time here
i think we have about a minute so you
just put it you paint it right on top
yeah the chicken paint it right up watch
this okay
because i have through the magic of
television one of them
actually in the oven just throw it on
like this
paint it throw these right on top
of the sheet pan really if i was
not stressed on time this would be much
thicker on the top okay
okay and into the oven we go
let me just pull one out for you hold on
just one minute
oh yeah we got to see that finished
product this looks delicious i might
make this this weekend
you will love it just take a look at
that just pulling this right out of the
chapman oven
and how do you like that that looks so
good
and i serve this with rice cauliflower
which you can see right over here
makes a great dish tonight or any night
you should plan dinner you've done it
again i love it honestly i think
that's that's fairly easy to make i
think i'm gonna do it this weekend
all right i'm gonna post the recipe on
nanny bubbe
and naomi bobby.com and you guys can
look it up
all right thank you so much guys check
out nanny bubby's kitchen
good to see you too check out nanny
bubby's kitchen and garden on social
media and
online at nannybubby.com we also want to
thank chapman automotive for sponsoring
this segment